哈囉大家好我是周慕姿心理師
今天又來到了十分鐘心理學
想要跟大家分享的這個題目呢
其實是關於批評以及指導
我不知道有沒有一個經驗
那就是你在跟別人互動的時候
有些人在給你一些就是建議的時候
聽起來特別不舒服啊
像是說例如說你給了一個東西
有一些數據
但是呢你給了你的主管之後
你的主管就說這數據有什麼屁用
你要這個數據要幹嘛
為什麼要放這個東西
你被連問了幾個問題
他雖然都沒有說你不行
但你就是覺得自己很不行
馬上就覺得自己很糟糕
可是我不知道你們遇過一個經驗
就是如果對方跟你想說
你有記得放數據這樣很好
可是呢這個數據呢
本身跟你現在後面的
資料好像沒有關係
所以我想你在這個部分
可能需要調整然後怎麼調整
你會不會覺得後面這個部分聽起來
好像就好多了
你就會覺得說好像為了
對方他這樣講
沒想要去做調整去做修改
你也不會有羞愧感
這就是為什麼
有些人在講東西
在給你建議的時候
你根本不覺得他是在為你好
根本是批評
但他又說是為你好
然後你還要把這個東西吃下來
會不會覺得很不舒服
而這就是我今天要跟大家討論的
這就是批評跟指導的差異
如果你是一個很喜歡給人建議的人
這一集很適合你
你可以問問你自己
你常常給的是批評還是指導呢
好那批評跟指導的差別是什麼呢
因為批評的重點
就是在告訴你哪裡錯了
所以在批評的這一個用詞中
常常會使用的就是增加
就是對你的評論以及否定的情緒
例如說這樣子不可以
你是不行的你是錯了
怎麼會做成這樣呢
還有一種很常用的批評做法
就是我有聽到很多人會被這樣子詢問
就是你為什麼會寫出這種東西
他沒有說你這個東西寫出來是不行的
他沒有任何的不行
可是你聽到他這個問句
加上剛剛的那個口氣
你有沒有就覺得好像很羞愧
你做了很錯的事情
然後如果你還跟他解釋說
你為什麼寫出這樣的東西
對方還會生氣
就說你還解釋
所以批評這件事情最麻煩的地方
就是因為他含有非常多的評論
以及否定的情緒
對方可能覺得他是
想要提醒你哪裡做錯
可是你會感覺到自己好像很糟糕
所以他會讓被批評者感覺到羞愧
然後甚至會想要防衛
有的時候更糟糕的是
會讓我們失去動力
所以當你很習慣用這樣的方式
跟自己講話的時候
你也會發現
你以為你在為自己好
你以為你在跟自己講哪裡
可以做得更好
但是為什麼你聽到自己跟自己說
天哪你做得好爛你好丟臉
或者是這個東西你怎麼會做成這樣
你有沒有想過別人會怎麼想你
你就會覺得你根本
不想要再去做任何調整
然後就很想要挖個
地洞把自己就是管起來
地洞把自己就是關起來
原因就是因為這會讓
我們感覺到很大的羞愧感
好 那再來我們回到指導
指導又是什麼
他跟批評的差別是什麼呢
指導的重點
反而是告訴我們這件事情
怎麼樣可以做得更好
請注意
剛剛的是你做錯了
你做得不夠好
批評就是你做得不夠好
但是指導是告訴你
怎麼樣可以做得更好
例如說他可能會有更明顯的告訴你
這邊要怎麼去調整
下一次可以試試看怎麼樣
所以用詞就像剛剛我舉了那個例子
當我今天給了一個報告
上面有數據
數據跟本身就是這一個
內容沒有太大的連結
對方的提醒就會是
你有記得付數據這樣很好
可是這部分的內容沒有連結
這個部分是需要調整的
所以我很清楚我怎麼調整
因此你就會發現
指導可以帶來的效果
其實是會讓被指導者清楚
可以怎麼改進
往哪個方向改進
而且還可以維持自我價值
所以你會發現
批評常常會讓我們停留在問題
跟錯誤本身
但指導會讓我們知道
怎麼樣可以解決
怎麼樣可以變得更好
所以那是一個很大的差別
再用一個更深的差別去說
就是批評很多時候是指出你的錯誤
所以有的時候你不會感覺到善意
但是指導你會感覺到真正的所謂
對方是為我好的善意
那個東西是存在的
那問題來啦
為什麼我們很習慣用批評
不太習慣用指導
我其實在跟我很多身邊的人
在討論這件事情覺得很有趣
因為有時候我會跟大家分享
我跟我先生的討論
我先生是一個做事情很嚴格的人
他對自己也很嚴格
就是傳說中的
就是對別人很狠
對自己更狠
但是我後來就發現
他很容易會在跟我
就是告訴我哪裡可以
做調整跟改變的時候
常常使用的就是批評的語句
而我覺得這件事情非常有趣
就是為什麼他常常會使用批評的語句
後來我發現
當我們從小常常經驗到被挑錯
被說不夠好
甚至對方是用比較
強烈的情緒說
你這個東西怎麼會做成這樣
天啊你怎麼會那麼笨
的時候
有的時候我們會把
這一個方法跟這個習慣
複製下來變成自己後來語言的習慣
甚至如果我們很常會對
自己做這樣的事情的時候
我們也很容易會對別人做
這件事情是很容易發生的
所以當我們今天如果
對這件事情很不耐煩
或是很焦慮很希望可控的時候
我們也很容易會用批評解決為什麼
因為他是我很常聽到
很容易選擇的方法
而且這個批評可以怎麼樣
這個批評可以讓我們直接發洩情緒
發洩自己的憤怒
發洩自己覺得對方沒有
做好不夠努力的地方
然後我們會因為這樣子
覺得舒服跟被安慰一點
還有很多時候批評會出現在
所謂上對下的關係
就是權力差異
因為基本來說下面的人
不會直接對上面的人
就是起衝突
對於上對下的關係
我不用同理你
我直接告訴你哪裡做錯了
而且帶有我的情緒
其實是比較能被包容的
對在台灣的社會是這樣
沒有錯
所以很多人不喜歡使用指導
喜歡用批評
一方面是我們學習來的的確是這樣
但另外一方面是
其實你就算用批評
在權力位階有一些差距的地方
不會一個成本沒有那麼高
就是你今天真的批評別人
別人也比較不敢對你怎麼樣
所以講難聽一點
為什麼你可以沒有同理心
因為周遭的人
允許你沒有同理心
那除此之外呢
如果用心理學的角度
為什麼我會比較鼓勵大家使用指導
而不是使用批評呢
雖然他看起來好像反正我批評別人
我有情緒
我把情緒丟到別人身上
然後我又沒什麼成本
那我為什麼不能
就一直用批評就好
有一個很大的原因
因為如果你真心希望
對方調整這件事情
批評本身比指導沒有用很多
也就是說
如果我們今天純粹
就只是為了發洩情緒
你使用批評
然後想要讓對方覺得你很棒
但他很爛
你用批評很快可以做到這件事
因為批評會觸發一個人的
羞愧跟防衛基準
因此當他被批評的時候
他就會覺得自己很糟糕
自己很爛
那你們的地位的確就已經
就是你在上他在下
但是批評也會造成一個結果
也就是說當你批評他的時候
有些人會屏蔽
有些人會防衛
因為我們不想去面對自己的羞愧感
所以我可能會想要反擊你
甚至我會把你的建議
整個屏蔽了
我不會吸收
所以其實被批評的時候
我們反而不容易去改善
我們原本想要改善的東西
但指導呢
指導是我告訴你方向
所以當我今天得到一個正向回饋
並且很清楚我什麼地方有做好
什麼地方沒有做好
我只要調整我沒有做好的地方就好
他保留了我的自尊
讓我維持我的自我價值
而且讓我很清楚
我可以往哪個方向
可以做到我想要的事情
這可以保持我的就是個人選擇的
自由意志
因此我會更願意嘗試
我也會更容易進步
很多研究指出
指導會比批評來得有效的很大原因
那聽到這裡
如果你是一些老師或是你是父母
甚至你日常生活
可能常常會需要跟
別人分享你的建議等等
你可能會想
那我要怎麼樣把批評變成指導呢
這裡我分享三個小技巧
大家可以練習看看
一開始第一個先承認對方的努力
還有對方做好或做對的事情
例如我看到你很用心整理資料
你有記得把數據資料放進來
這個部分很好
再點出問題
可是這邊的數據跟結論是沒有連結的
有點可惜
用詞上盡量不要有太多的評價
這件事情很重要
你可以就是論事的
把這一個狀態直接說出來
也不用有很多的形容詞
那其實也沒有很糟糕
你就是不用不用不用這些東西
就是很直白的
把你看到的東西直接說出來
最後再給他方向與方法
例如如果這邊數據
你可以再看一下
你想要呈現的結論
盡量去找跟這個結論
跟你想呈現的部分有關的數據
我們會比較能夠理解
為什麼你會給出這樣的結論
或者是鼓勵對方用圖表
用怎麼樣的方式來呈現更清楚等等
所以告訴他很清楚怎麼做
會變得更好
是你覺得更好的方向等等
是我們可以採取的一個技巧
因此在這裡帶給大家一個口訣
那就是看見努力指出問題
提出方法
在這個狀態
用溫柔的心說直白的話
我認為這件事情是沒有問題的
所以對大家來說可能會覺得
哇塞原來批評跟指導有這樣的差別
我覺得這是一件很有趣的事情
因為當我們今天
毫不留情說出批評的時候
其實某方面也是我們的一個防衛機轉
因為我們想要表現
我跟你不一樣
我可以看出這個
你怎麼會沒看出
甚至我其實某方面
是用批評在責備對方
或是在展現出我對他的失望
因此如果能夠瞭解到我為什麼要批評
為什麼我很習慣用批評
也不是用批評自己的方式去看
為什麼我要批評
是先去理解為什麼我會習慣批評
我想達到的結果是什麼
當你知道了這件事情有意識之後
我想你就會更容易的
能夠選擇對人比較有幫助的指導
他能夠幫助你和他人
建立比較良好的合作關係
也可以讓你很安全的分享出
想給別人的建議
因此這次批評與指導
我覺得是一個我們常常會遇到
但是也許大家沒有留意到的一個
日常溝通的一個困難
想把這個部分分享給大家
希望對大家有幫助
那麼就周慕姿放心說
我們下次見囉
拜拜
批評本身比指導沒有用很多
批評本身他的有用處的
也就是說
如果我們今天純粹
就只是為了發洩情緒
你使用批評
然後想要讓對方覺得你很棒
但他很爛
你用批評很快可以做到這件事
因為批評會觸發一個人的
修繪跟防衛基準
因此當他被批評的時候
他就會覺得自己很糟糕
自己很爛
那你們的地位的確就已經
就是你在上他在下
但是批評也會造成一個結果
也就是說當你批評他的時候
有些人會屏蔽
有些人會防衛
因為我們不想去面對自己的修繪感
所以我可能會想要反擊你
甚至我會把你的建議
整個屏蔽了
我不會洗手
所以其實被批評的時候
我們反而不容易去改善
我們原本想要改善的東西
但指導呢
指導是我告訴你方向
所以當我今天得到一個正向回饋
並且很清楚我什麼地方有做好
什麼地方沒有做好
我只要調整我沒有做好的地方就好
他保留了我的自尊
讓我維持我的自我價值
而且讓我很清楚
我可以往哪個方向
可以做到我想要的事情
這可以保持我的就是個人選擇的
自由意志
因此我會更願意嘗試
我也會更容易進步
而這也是研究
就是很多研究指出
指導會比批評來得有效的很大原因
指導可以帶來的效果
其實是會讓被指導者清楚
可以怎麼改進
往哪個方向改進
而且還可以維持自我價值
所以你會發現
批評常常會讓我們停留在問題
跟錯誤本身
但指導會讓我們知道
怎麼樣可以解決
怎麼樣可以變得更好
所以那是一個很大的差別
再用一個更深的差別去說
就是批評很多時候是指出你的錯誤
所以有的時候你不會感覺到善意
但是指導你會感覺到真正的所謂
對方是為我好的善意
那個東西是存在的